the first type of problem I want to show
you is where the degree and the
denominator is higher than the degree in
the numerator so what happens as X gets
larger and larger this whole fraction
okay
is going to go to zero okay so what that
means is that you're going to have a
horizontal asymptote at y equals zero so
I'm just gonna sketch that in right here
okay so there's your horizontal
asymptote now the next thing you want to
do is you want to factor this polynomial
as much as you can because if there's a
factor that is in the numerator that
cancels with a factor in the denominator
that means that you're going to have a
hole in the graph okay removable
discontinuity and we want to pay
attention to that so let's go ahead and
factor this will be factored we get an X
minus 1 ok f of x equals X minus 1 over
X minus 4x plus 3 okay so we didn't have
a factor in the numerator that cancel
with a fashion the denominator so we
don't have any holes in our graph but we
know that the denominator can't equal
zero because if you you know divide by
zero that's undefined so what's going to
happen here is we're gonna set these
factors in the denominator is 0 and we
get x equals 4 and x equals negative 3
and what that tells us is we're gonna
have a vertical asymptote at those
locations on the graph so x equals 4
okay 1 2 3 4 I'm gonna draw a dotted
line a dashed line okay it's invisible X
cannot equal 4 over here X can also not
equal negative 3 so let's draw that in
there okay so this is a negative 3 and
this is 4 okay so we've got our
asymptotes now we want to look for some
additional points to help us draw a nice
graph here so some easy points to find
our go ahead and make a little table
like this find X and y intercepts so if
you set X to 0 okay you see you're gonna
get negative 1 over negative 12 which is
112 and if you set Y to 0 okay that f of
X is y the output if we set Y to 0 but
only the way that Y will be
zero is if the numerator of this
fraction is equal to zero so the only
way the numerator be zero is FX equals 1
so 1 minus 1 is 0 so we can see there's
going to be an x intercept at 1 so let's
go ahead and plot those points so we've
got 1 and we've got 0 comma 112 which is
right about there okay the next thing
you want to do and different teachers
will explain this to you a little bit
differently depending on their preferred
method but you can either pick points on
either side of the asymptotes like I
might pick x equals 3 or x equals 5 and
then you can plot some points because
what happens is as the graph approaches
the vertical asymptote it can't cross
the vertical asymptote it either has to
go down towards negative infinity or up
towards positive infinity and by
plotting a few extra points you can get
a sense of what happens with the graph
but the other method which I'm going to
show you right here is to do a sign
analysis and so what you're gonna do is
you're gonna pick a point okay that's
just a little bit to the left of the
vertical asymptote and a point that's
just a little bit to the right so if I
pick for example like 3 we're going to
analyze the signs excuse me so if I put
3 in here we're gonna get 3 minus 1 is 2
which is positive 3 minus 4 which is
negative and 3 plus 3 which is 6 which
is positive now a negative times a
positive is a negative a positive
divided by a negative is a negative so
what that means is that when you're
approaching from the right here at x
equals 3 we're getting a negative value
it tells us that the graph is going down
like that now let's pick five so you're
approaching this vertical asymptote from
the right side now if we put 5 and we're
going to get a positive okay and the
denominator positive and a positive so
positive times a positive is a positive
a positive divided by a positive is a
positive so as we approach from this
direction the graph is going to be going
up here is gonna be approaching this
horizontal asymptote
now let's approach this vertical
asymptote from the right side and the
left side let's put in negative 2 so
negative 2 would give us a negative an
egg
and a positive negative times a positive
is a negative a negative divided by a
negative is a positive so you can see
this graph is going to be going up here
and if we pick negative 4 we're
approaching from this direction we're
gonna get negative negative negative so
negative times a negative is a positive
a negative divided by a positive is a
negative so what that tells us is that
this graph is going to be going down
when it approaches from this direction
so now you can see your graphs gonna go
through these points we found earlier
like that and it's going to approach the
horizontal asymptotes now another quick
note about asymptotes notice you can
cross a horizontal asymptote okay
because that's really just saying that
as X approaches infinity as X approaches
negative infinity you're going to be
approaching that horizontal line but the
vertical asymptotes you cannot cross
because if you cross this point you're
going to be dividing by 0 which is
undefined so this is one example okay
and this was the example I wanted to
show you where the denominators degree
was higher than the numerators degree
and that's when you get a horizontal
asymptote at y equals 0 ok let's look at
another example ok so in this example
we're going to look at where there's a
tie okay between the highest degree in
the denominator and the highest degree
in the numerator so the one I want to
show you here I'm on the right already
in factored form okay and this one is f
of X equals X minus 6 times X plus 2
over X minus 6 times X plus 1 so if you
were to foil this out you would see that
the highest degree term would be x
squared over x squared x squared divided
by x squared okay it's a tie between the
degrees which means they're growing at
the same rate so as X gets larger and
larger you're gonna approach the ratio
of the coefficients in front of these
terms so in this case it's just 1 over 1
the horizontal asymptote is going to be
y equals 1 ok so let's go ahead and
graph this one okay so that's y equals 1
now in the denominator you can see we
don't want the denominator to be 0 but
see how there's a factor in the
denominator that cancels with the factor
in the numerator these X minus 6 factors
so we're not going to get a vertical
asymptote at x equals 6 we're gonna get
a whole ok like this a removable
discontinuity at x equals 6 and the way
that you find the y coordinate of the
hole is you cancel these out substitute
is 6 in for x and you're left with 8
over 7 okay because in essence x cannot
equal 6 because you can't divide by 0
but the way the graph is going to behave
is as if it was X plus 2 over X plus 1
so by putting in that x coordinate that
makes this denominator 0 here you can
find the y coordinate of the hole okay
so let's go ahead and graph that so this
is 1 2 3 4 5 6 8 7th is just a little
bit above
like that okay there's the whole next
thing we're gonna do is we're gonna go
to the table and we're gonna plot some
points okay before we do that let's look
at this other vertical asymptote at x
equals negative 1 because we can't
divide by zero so there's a vertical
asymptote at x equals negative 1 ok like
that okay so now let's look at some
additional points so we're going to find
the x and y intercepts you're going to
set X to 0 if we do that we get negative
6 times 2 over negative 6 times 1
these cancel we get 2 over 1 which is 2
so we know the graph is crossing at 2 a
0 comma 2 and if we set Y to 0 the only
way this will be 0 is if the numerator
is 0 because 0 divided by anything
that's not 0 will be 0 and so you can
see that's going to be negative 2 so
this graphs going to cross over here at
negative 2 right there so the graph
shaping up for us pretty well the only
other thing I would do is just analyze
as you approach this graph from the
right and from the left the vertical
asymptote the graph either has to go
down or up towards positive finding
negative infinity same thing I would
approach from the right and left ok so
let's let's maybe pick like a negative
0.9 okay so if we put in negative 0.9
these these are basically cancelling
each other out so by putting a negative
0.9 we're going to get a positive and a
positive and a positive every bite of is
a positive so that tells us this graph
is going to be going like this up
towards positive infinity you probably
guessed that just by the points that we
already had and then over here let's put
in negative 1.1 that's going to make
this positive but that's going to make
this negative this time positive I by
negative is a negative
so that means this graphs going to be
going down towards negative infinity as
you approach this graph from from this
direction so notice there was a hole in
this graph that was a little bit
different okay and that's because these
factors cancel the numerator and
denominator also what was interesting
about this problem is that we had
hi between the highest degree term in
the numerator in the denominator and we
had the ratio of the coefficients which
gave us our horizontal asymptote of y
equals 1 okay the third example I want
to show you is a little bit different
yet and in this example what we're
actually going to get is we're going to
get a slant asymptote or a diagonal
asymptote and that occurs when the
degree of the highest term in the
numerator is higher than the degree in
the denominator so let me see if I can
show you an example of that okay we're
gonna graph this one as well and so the
one I've come up here with for you is f
of X equals and I've already factored
this for you but if it's not in factored
form the first thing I would do is
factor just so you can see what the
components are okay so we're going to
look at this one here so notice if we
were to foil this out we would get x
squared over X so the degree in the
numerator is higher than the degree in
the denominator so what you want to do
in this case is you actually want to do
long division or synthetic division so
let's just simplify this this is going
to be x squared plus 2x minus 3 we're
going to be dividing by X plus 2 and
this goes in x times and we're left with
negative 3 now you don't have to worry
about the remainder so when this degree
is lower than this our slant asymptote
is going to be at y equals x so we know
that y equals x is a 45 degree line like
this okay and so that's our slant
asymptote the graph will approach that
line we also know that we can't divide
by 0 so we're gonna have a vertical
asymptote at x equals negative 2 okay
and then if we make a table like we did
in the some of the other problems we're
gonna set X to 0 and we're going to set
Y to 0 so if we set X to 0 we get
negative 1 times 3 over 2 which is
negative 3
halves negative 1.5 and if we set Y to 0
the only way that Y will be 0 okay Y
will be 0 is if the numerator is 0 but
the denominator is not 0 so in this case
that would be at 1 and negative 3 so
we'll just say 1 and negative 3 so
that's going to be here here and 0
negative 3 halves was going to be right
here so you can see without even
graphing any additional points that this
graph is actually going to look like
this and it's going to look like this so
it's approaching the two asymptotes as
you go to the left and to the right but
you can plot additional points you can
also do the sign analysis we talked
about in the earlier problems by picking
some points on either side of the
vertical asymptotes to see if it's going
up or down so these have been the three
different types that you'll come across
the most where you have in this case the
degree in the numerator is higher than
the degree in the denominator you do the
long division for the slant asymptote or
it's a tie between the two degrees then
you get the ratio of the coefficients
and then if the denominators power is
higher than the numerators it's just
going to be the x axis is your
horizontal asymptote y equals 0 so this
has been a good overview of how to do
graph rational functions I'll see you in
the next video